Tyler when you came to LA I'm sorry how
long ago was it three years ago two
years ago two years ago forget me okay
did you have a plan in place for
auditioning and getting an agent and
manager and then if it didn't work out
you also had a back-up plan it's it's
that's a funny that's a funny question
it's very it's a very good question so I
have a very strong opinion in regards to
Plan B's I think that if you have a plan
B that life will push you to addressing
and confronting that Plan B and so if
that Plan B is in place it's all too
easy to to go with that so with me this
is my plan ABCD all the way through Z
and and the result is is a feeling of
resiliency that says anything external
any setbacks and the obstacles that are
external are only going to be temporary
because my internal drive to get things
done and to and to and to really make a
name for myself in this business is is
only extinguish will by one thing and
that's that's the end of the road so
there's no stop for me and I think as
soon as you start thinking about a plan
B I think it's too late I think you just
you're giving up right away even for me
it's hard I've been trying to do this
for like 12 years or something and it's
a long time and if you think oh then I'm
gonna be a lawyer like makes no sense
you know it's like you commit and if it
takes 30 years it's gonna take 30 years
but you can think about a plan B even if
sometime you're struggling you want you
know you wanna die or whatever it's like
you have to put keep pushing you push
push push and then you hope that one day
something is gonna happen and after all
those years for me now I'm just I'm I'm
at the point of doing my first feature
film now just got a funding for the
second one so it's like things start
smooth but it takes you know 15 years or
so so you can think about a plan B and
same thing I think for any kind of
artist painting whatever actors or
sometimes you think that I think it's
kind of drew you're kind of killing
yourself or soul a little bit and you
know it just to add one thing to that so
I'm a boxer I started boxing in Brooklyn
many years ago and I now boxed out here
as well and they have a slogan in the
gym
above the ring and it says it ain't easy
and it's supposed to apply to training
and to but it also extends into life as
well and I think that this business
ain't easy I know this is poor grammar
but this business ain't easy life ain't
easy a struggle isn't easy and and the
result is that yeah you got to be tough
to make in this business and you got to
be resilient and I think resiliency is
that is a number one key because you're
gonna get beaten down just like in
boxing but it's how you get back up that
really makes a difference
so is that choosing but but I believe
sign no that's great I mean do you do
you carry that sign sort of as a
metaphor for your life let's suppose you
had a bad audition or maybe one that was
great and they loved you when you walked
in the room and of course as Murphy's
Law you don't get it for some reason
so where are you when you don't get that
phone call because a lot of times I
don't call sure well you know I think a
lot of it has to do with where you're
based are you processed based or you or
you more outcome based and for me I find
myself at the happiest when I'm process
to have a process based mentality and
and the sort of consequence of that is
is that you become divorced from the
outcome itself and so if you go if I
went into the room I did the kind of
work that I set out to do I made clear
choices I was prepared then ultimately
when I go in there I'm doing it for me
I'm not doing it for the room I'm not
doing it for the director I'm not even
doing it for material really I'm doing
it for me and and when I walk out that
same same kind of mantra holds holds
true I did it for me and what they had
what their reaction was that's you know
who cares about what they think the same
thing with the future of him I did it I
did it for myself someone loved it some
will hate it
some will love this guy some will hate
it it's part of life you know I mean
it's like you can not please anybody as
long as you gave your all you did it for
yourself move on after that you know I
mean think about something else and even
if you did short term that was not
successful I didn't I didn't go in
festivals or stuff like that or even
people like oh my god it's horrible move
on you know you can you have to have a
strong back to be able to get roll off a
little bit but you just you just move on
and just who cares and I've told to act
her so many times that they killed it
they did an amazing job and it's like
but you're not right for it but you did
an amazing job but just you know
continue keep pushing and it's gonna
happen you just have it's not just about
doing an audition you need to fit the
role perfectly so so no he's totally
right what he just said and I also think
it has a lot to do as well it's sort of
a gut check on on what you're and only
you can answer this question for
yourself but what your motivations are
and getting involved in in any art form
and any side of the camera you know I
like to use like you know the allegory
of a of a cobbler like a line of vendors
you know you got one one vendor who has
got who's got a set of shoes and he says
hey I'm someone's shoes cuz I I really
want to get famous you know the next guy
on the line says you know I'm selling
shoes because I just really want to get
rich and the guy down the third guy down
the line says hey I'm selling shoes
because I love making shoes I love
here's the leather it's been imported
from here here the laces it's a it's a
you know it's an age-old tradition this
kind of thing and that that kind of love
that kind of passion that kind of
craftsmanship and it beats anything
yeah and that's something that I mean if
there's one thing that I aspire to be
it's a craftsman and I want to be that
third cobbler if possible was was there
a time you can recount where let's say
you did get beaten down you know you're
in LA you get cut off in traffic all the
stuff happens you're like you know what
I'm not sure that I really want to be
here anymore and then you reminded
yourself that I don't know what else I'd
be doing other than this yes in fact not
too long ago I I came out here with with
an agent and it was an agent who I was
set up with because of a relationship I
was in prior a romantic relationship I
just wasn't a good fit and and we parted
ways and we parted ways not too long ago
and I had and I had a little bit of that
dark night of the soul to use a little
save the cat terminology I put
ultimately I got picked up by someone
unless someone it really believes in me
and who
and who's and who's really willing to
stick their neck out for me to take a
chance on me and you know during that
dark night I had to ask myself you know
am I gonna allow this one particular
perspective to influence how I feel
about myself or am I gonna be the
driving force behind my own my own fate
my own destiny whatever you want to call
it and and ultimately I felt like I get
in the driver's seat so and there's a
lot of that in this business of with
this kind of passive attitude towards
getting work which is I hope my phone
rings well you got to make your phone
ring you know you can't just wait for it
to rain shots gonna bring out his own so
that was just sort of a one-night
process or did it I mean I think I mean
there's been many and I anticipate
confronting many more of those sorts of
gut check moments but I think really
which have to defer back to is exactly
like you started the question out on
which is without having a plan B you
think what else could I possibly do what
else could I be
could I be disconnected to and and and
for me there is nothing else so it's not
a hard choice in those moments it's more
choice of it's more question of okay
what do we do now as opposed to let's
cut and run you know so you know they
always say you gotta fight your way out
of the corner you know and they're not
just gonna let you out you gotta fight
your way out of the corner sorry you're
back to boxing from that
you